[Musique]
si je vous dis confinement ça vous
rappelle vaguement quelque chose non
alors imaginez confinement c'est au 1
je viens de terminer ma façon puzzle et
je me suis mis en tête de faire du pain
alors évidemment le résultat ne
ressemble pas du tout à la photo de la
recette et ça c'est un détail
du coup j'ai les mains dans la farine
quand mon téléphone vibre sur mon écran
je lis virus gargarisme boissons chaudes
c'est michel mon copain photographe qui
m'envoie une liste de conseils pour
neutraliser lakovic 19
il me demande si l'information tient la
route je suis journaliste
alors depuis le début de la pandémie je
suis devenu une sorte de tour de
contrôle de l'information
la barrière anti fait keynews de mes
amis ce message on l'a tous reçu celui
qui nous conseillaient de retenir notre
respiration pendant 10 secondes et de
boire de l'eau chaude pour faire glisser
le virus dans l'estomac
si vous vous souvenez bien ils étaient
censés provenir d'une cousine
pneumologue d'un ami médecin un expert
quoi est quelqu'un d'assez proche
il terminait tout en retenue par
partager cette information
la solidarité et le sens civique compte
rien que ça alors j'aime bien cet
exemple et je les aime bien parce qu'on
y retrouve tous les ingrédients d'une
bonne fée qui news c'est un message qui
un sort sur nos angoisses et deux
affirment sans preuve
alors il faut se replacer un petit peu
dans le contexte
fin mars on savait très peu de choses
sur le virus et comme la nature a
horreur du vide
on a comblé on a transformé nos
suppositions en évidence et pour
conjurer l'angoissent on a cherché des
réponses un peu partout et pas toujours
au bon endroit en même temps ça fait des
années qu'on nous bassine avec le lâcher
prise
j'adore le concept du lâcher prise
bon je pense qu'après ces quelques mois
à jongler entre toutes les injonctions
contradictoires
on est tous passés maître maître jedi
dans l'art de l'impro du coup forcément
quand un proche nous envoie un message
bourré de bon sens qui propose des
réponses on a envie d'y croire
on a envie de se dire que si on boit
quatre litres de thé dans la journée on
la trappe rapaces virus plutôt que
d'affronter les vertiges de
l'incertitude on préfère figer le monde
on colle un visage à nos peurs on les
appelle les chinois les juifs bill gates
des forces qu'on imagine tapis dans
l'ombre en train de manipuler la marche
du monde entre deux coupes de champagne
et un rire sardonique
on prend le réel et on en le
transformant récit on lui impose à la
fois une cohérence et une
intentionnalité on prend toutes nos
angoisses et on les jette dans un super
grand saladier et puis on mélange on
mélange jusqu'à perdre le sens des
réalités
jusqu'à se dire que finalement ce virus
il existe pas ou variante
particulièrement créative que la reine
elizabeth est un lézard extraterrestre
ça vous fait sourire
vous trouvez que j'ai un peu loin on
parle beaucoup de complotisme ces
derniers temps
cette distorsion qui consiste à voir des
complots partout mais personne ne tombe
dedans du jour au lendemain on commence
par une petite théorie sur la cia à la
sauce hollywood par des petites phrases
facile sans arguments sur les élites et
les vaccins et puis progressivement on
sacrifie la raison sur l'autel de la
méfiance
c'est tellement plus simple alors les
vrais complots ça existe mais entre nous
sont rarement découvert par un excité du
clavier qui entre deux saillies sur les
rothschild assure détenir la preuve
d'une invasion extraterrestre
je vous parle théorie du complot au
complot fait qu'ils nous informent qs
plainte terme
évidemment ce n'est pas exactement la
même chose et je vous rassure
le fait d'avoir déjà partagé une fée qui
news ne fait pas de vous un complotiste
mais c'est vrai qu'on retrouve des
mécanismes et des pièges en commun on
appelle ça globalement la désinformation
justement la désinformation elles
exploitent nos préjugés et nos biais
cognitifs alors qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un biais cognitif
c'est un raccourci qu'emprunte la pensée
et qui alternent au jugement et qu'on
soit jeune ou vieux hommes ou femmes
diplômées ou non on en est tous victimes
ont parlé des extraterrestres il ya
quelques minutes
mais soyons réalistes ce ne sont pas les
ufologues et leur chasse aux ovnis qui
menacent la démocratie c'est vous moi et
tous nos petits arrangements avec les
faits toutes ces fois où par un savant
mélange de flemme et d'indignation on
partage un contenu qu'on n'a pas tout à
fait lui jusqu'au bout toutes ces fois
où on accepte une information totalement
bidon sens il est simplement parce
qu'elle confirme une opinion qu'on a
déjà
en fait pour se simplifier la vie au
quotidien on cède du terrain et
l'exercice de la raison et ça c'est déjà
glissé un pied dans la porte du
complotisme parce que je suis désolé de
vous le dire mais complotistes on l'est
tous un petit peu par paresse et puis
parce qu'on adore les histoires de
sociétés secrètes et de méchants déguisé
en batman après on entretient une
relation assez compliqué à la notion de
source
vous vous souvenez de michel est sombre
de sape sur les boissons chaudes et
lakovic 19 mai michel moi j'aime bien
c'est un super bon photographe et puis
j'adore son cynisme alors quand il
m'envoie un message ben j'ai tendance à
baisser la garde
justement cette tendance une équipe de
chercheurs affiliés à l'american press
institute l'a étudié en 2017 et ils ont
découvert que l'identité de la personne
qui partage un contenu sur internet est
la nature du lien qui nous relie à elle
importe plus que la fiabilité de sa
source en gros
vous allez considéré comme beaucoup plus
fiable l'obscur tweet que vient de vous
partager votre meilleur ami et vous
allez avoir tendance à vous méfier de
l'article de libération que vient de
vous transférez latente que vous pouvez
pas encadré évidemment je ne vous
apprends rien si je vous dis qu une
profonde défiance s'est instauré entre
les citoyens les médias et plus
largement les institutions résultat on a
tous une grande facilité à concevoir
pourquoi une entreprise ou un
gouvernement se lancerait dans la
production de freenews
en revanche on accorde du crédit sans
difficulté à la vidéo d'un nom connu
trouvait au détour d'une recommandation
et youtube pourquoi pas parce que on
s'identifie aux trentenaires qui pousse
un coup de gueule sur les big pharma
dans sa voiture puisqu'il nous ressemble
pourquoi il nous mentirait bas parce
qu'il existe des raisons éminemment
rationnelle de produire des faits qui
news et des théories du complot des
raisons politiques la propagande existe
depuis la nuit des temps mais aussi
psychologique on jubile quand on raconte
une rumeur on adore être celui qui sait
celui qu'on écoute
celui qui ne se fait pas à voir dans ces
cas là notre biais de confiance
excessive fonctionne à plein régime
on surestime nos connaissances et notre
capacité de jugement
un exemple tout bête on a toujours
l'impression après deux verres d'alcool
en prenant le volant que ce n'est pas la
fin du monde
parce que nous on tient bien l'alcool
alors je vous dis nous mais c'est par
pure solidarité sur ce coup là parce que
moi après deux verres de cidre je cite
gandalf donc personne n'est assez fou
pour me donner le volant mais vous avez
compris l'idée la désinformation
c'est comme les accidents on part
toujours du principe que ça n'arrive
qu'aux autres
mais si la désinformation galope sur le
net c'est parce qu'il ya un marché et
qui dit marché dit consommateur est donc
revenu on peut se faire des fortunes en
falsifiant d'information et ça
l'américain cameron harris l'a très bien
compris
je vous propose de remonter un peu dans
le temps donc en avant 2016 aux états
unis
les arbres commencent un peu à perdre
leurs feuilles et le candidat
républicain donald trump s'essouffle
dans les sondages à l'époque cameron
harris à 23 ans les passionnés de
politique mais il a besoin d'argent et
quelques jours plus tôt donald trump a
pour la première fois évoqué dans un
discours dans l'ohio
ces suspicions ils accusent la candidate
hillary clinton de s'apprêter à
falsifier l'élection présidentielle
alors si vous avez un sentiment de déjà
vu c'est parfaitement normal il employer
exactement la même stratégie il ya
quelques mois face à joe biden mais du
coup
cameron harris malins ils voient une
opportunité et il se lance dans la
production d'une feuille qui news une
information contrefaites
son pitch randall prins un électricien
aurait découvert des milliers de
bulletins validés au nom de la candidate
démocrate hillary clinton dans un
entrepôt je vous laisse deviner ou dans
l'ohio
harris utilise les éléments de langage
de trump créé de fausses citations
ajoute une photo qu'il a prise sur
google images et tape une rapide les
jaunes en quelques semaines son article
a été partagé plus de six millions de
fois 6 millions or six millions de
partage c'est beaucoup d'argent grâce au
système de publicité intégrée les
fameuses google a dit à chaque fois
qu'un internaute clique sur l'article et
arrive sur son site
il touche quelques centimes pour résumer
5 dollars pour acheter un nom de domaine
un quart d'heure pour écrire une fake
news et 5000 dollars à la clé rentable
alors pourquoi ça marche parce que
cameron harris a donné exactement les
preuves que les militants pro trump
attendait il a ici exploiter ce que les
psychologues cognitiviste appelle le
biais de confirmation
notre tendance à tous à rechercher
sélectionnés et mémoriser en priorité
les informations qui confirment nos
croyances et nos préjugés
mais attention la désinformation n'a
évidemment pas attendu internet pour se
développer
si vous lisez l'art de la garde du
stratège chinois jun zhu
vous allez vous rendre compte qu'ils
donnent déjà des astuces pour créer des
fiches news et l'essai
du vième siècle avant jésus-christ
pourtant il ya quelque chose de propre à
notre époque a l'air de l'intelligence
artificielle et de la mise en réseau je
vous parlais du biais de confirmation ce
biais de confirmation
les géants du net le connaissent très
bien pour nous garder le plus longtemps
possible sur leurs plateformes
instagram youtube facebook ont compris
qu'il fallait nous proposer du contenu
qui nous intéresse résultat ils étudient
nos profils nos passions nos opinions
politiques
le nombre de secondes que l'on passe à
regarder la photo d'un ex un samedi soir
de déprime
le nombre d'articles que l'on consulte
et toutes ces informations sont ensuite
exploités par leurs algorithmes qui
élaborent nos fils d'actualités hainaut
liste de recommandations j'ai deux
comptes facebook
un premier qui me sert à poster mes
photos de vacances comme tout le monde
et un deuxième sur lequel j'échange avec
mes étudiants et qui me permet de faire
quelques recherches pour mes articles ce
sont deux mondes parallèles
le premier est sponsorisé par le new
york times et radio france ce qui n'est
pas extrêmement étonnant dans la mesure
où la moitié de mes amis sont
journalistes
le second en revanche me propose de
regarder la dernière vidéo du pape du
conspirationnisme david icke et me
proposent des postes au titre très
travaillée du style découvrez la vérité
trois points de suspension le résultat
va vous surprendre
l'algorithme de facebook sculpte le
monde virtuel de près de 3 milliards
d'internautes
alors quand les réseaux sociaux nous
disent que ce ne sont que des
agrégateurs de contenus c'est faux ce
sont des éditeurs qui façonnent nos
représentations du monde
le tournant des années 2000 marquent la
fin du monopole des journalistes sur
l'information aujourd'hui suffit d'être
équipé d'une connexion internet pour
pouvoir partager produire ou éditer du
contenu c'est évidemment un signe de
vitalité démocratique
le problème c'est qu'en ces géants du
net se mettent à cloisonner les facettes
du réel quant au lieu d'ouvrir notre
champ des possibles il nous propose en
prime
étaient des informations qui confirment
nos préjugés et nos croyances sur le
monde alors ne vous inquiétez pas je
vous sens un petit peu inquiet ce n'est
pas une fatalité mais c'est vrai que
pour briser cet engrenage
il faut s'y employer activement nous
devons accepter de sortir de notre zone
de confort accepter parfois d'avoir tort
comprendre qu'avant d'être un discours à
combattre une opinion contraire est une
fabuleuse opportunité celle d'explorer
le monde autrement d'emprunter de
nouveau chemin
les philosophes des lumières avait
choisi comme credo ça paierait à aude et
aux savoirs ou aux pensées par toi même
comme eux je suis convaincu que plus
qu'une compétences à acquérir l'esprit
critique
c'est une hygiène de vie en 2021 les
médias ce n'est plus simplement le monde
france inter ou lci c'est vous - hainaut
compte instagram
alors on peut s'indigner de la
prolifération des fakes news sur
internet on peut crier à l'incompétence
des journalistes mais en réalité si la
désinformation galope c'est parce qu'on
est là pour la lire est ce que vous
savez qu'une feuille news à 70% de
chances de plus d'être partagé sur
twitter qu'une information vérifiée
c'est le résultat affolons d'une étude
qui a été menée par le mi6 en 2017
alors ce n'est pas entièrement de notre
faute il faut savoir qu'en cinq ans on a
produit plus de données que l'ensemble
des ouvrages qui ont été imprimés depuis
gutenberg
vous imaginez chaque jour nous sommes
assaillis par un flot continu de données
de fait d'opinions qui sollicitent notre
attention
or cette surcharge elle érode notre
capacité à faire la différence entre le
vrai et le faux
ça fait cinq ans que j'épluche le net
complotistes et de ses très longues
heures
croyez moi à contempler les affres de la
créativité humaine
j'ai retenu trois enseignements mon
premier conseil quand une information
génère une émotion forte on doit être
extrêmement vigilant si un poste
vous attriste vous indignez vous met en
colère
il faut se méfier les émotions négatives
c'est la planche à billet de la
désinformation et accessoirement des
géants du net
ma deuxième astuces quand une
information confirme un stéréotype
il faut procéder avec beaucoup de
prudence le réel ressemblent rarement à
l'idée qu'on s'en fait du coup exercer
son esprit critique c'est avant tout
penser contre soi même une dernière mise
en garde
quand un internaute vous promets la
vérité passez votre chemin
la vérité c'est un concept philosophique
que je trouve très complexes exigeant je
lui préfère de très loin la notion
beaucoup plus terre à terre
de fait et d'ailleurs en tant que
journaliste c'est ce à quoi je m'engage
vous rapporter les faits avec exactitude
et c'est déjà pas si mal
inutile de vous préciser ou de vous
rappeler qu'il est absolument
indispensable que vous vérifiez et de
recouper les informations que vous
partagez sur internet
c'est vraiment un conseil tout bête et
qui évite tellement d'erreurs parce que
vous avez des comptes twitter instagram
facebook vos voix compte et les
informations que vous partagez résonne
d'autant que les miennes alors je pense
qu'il est un petit peu temps aussi que
nous partagions la responsabilité qui
est associé l'exercice de l'esprit
critique est indispensable la critique
des médias l'est tout autant
mais elle ne peut pas et ne doit pas
faire l'économie de la rationalité
le doute est un outil précieux c'est lui
qui fait progresser la science depuis
des millénaires
c'est lui qui nous ouvre de nouveaux
chemins de connaissances en droit mais
qui s'accompagne de responsabilités des
responsabilités sur lesquels nos
démocraties se sont construites alors
douté mais douter avec l'intransigeance
intellectuels dont le monde a tant
besoin
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]